welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Julia Adams professor of sociology
and professor of international and area
studies at yale university professor
adams teaches and conducts research in
the areas of state formation gender &
family social theory early modern
european politics colonialism and empire
she is currently studying large-scale
forms of patriarchal politics and to the
historical sociology of agency relations
today we'll talk with her about her
earlier research on the familial state
and her newer work on contradictions of
agency in contemporary America welcome
professor Adams Thank You Marilyn and
please call me Julia okay your earlier
work the book you wrote entitled the
familial state dealt with a study of the
role of elite families in large-scale
political development in European
countries like the Netherlands France
and England can you tell us something
about this role and how it mattered I
can thank you well it mattered in two
basic ways both of course course which
are important to to me one is to
scholarship and the other is to a better
understanding of the world around us in
scholarship basically for a long time
there has been a puzzle about the
historical rise and fall of the
Netherlands and here I'm talking about
what is known as the early modern period
about fifteen to eighteen hundred the
Netherlands was a very tiny state very
small in population and yet it rose to a
position of great world power and what
you will know as the Dutch Golden Age in
politics and economics and of course
also in culture
in art and other affiliated activities
so the Dutch did stupendously well and
that has always puzzled people because
of the small comparative size of the
country and its relative weakness in the
18th century things reverse quite
dramatically the Netherlands declined
and didn't quote-unquote come up again
until the 20th century when in fact the
country came roaring back so that's the
basic scholarly puzzle and also a
broader puzzle for all the citizens of
any nation state that are interested in
why their particular country might do
well well in one ERA and not so well in
another so scholars have examined this
for centuries actually and have found or
have advanced many explanations and
quite a few of those hold at least some
water economic explanations explanations
that focus on the role of other
contenders in the world system my
contribution was to highlight the role
of elite families in both advancing the
economic and political and familial
fortunes of their own families and
therefore the country at large and then
in the 18th century torpedoing them and
I can explain more about that if you're
interested or okay so how is it possible
that a group of elite families both
helped and then hurt the Dutch state
well in the earlier period these
families were many things they were
merchant capitalists they were
politicians nascent politicians that is
the occupied state offices and their
families occupied state offices and they
were also patriarchs concerned to
advance the fortunes of their families
at any one time and then entered
generationally in the Golden Age this
inspired them to world-beating
achievements in
many many areas they became however
increasingly invested in their hold on
pieces of privilege and on the state and
they had quite a wide hold or grip on
the state on the east and west indies
companies on many aspects of dutch life
it became more and more difficult to
consider giving that up and those
arrangements became more and more rigid
and less and less suited to the needs of
the day that was a key to the downfall
of the dutch in the 18th century okay
are any of these arguments relevant
today do they apply for example to
countries that are still ruled by
families like Saudi Arabia and it's
40-some ruling brothers that's a very
good question i think i think these
questions are open still and many people
are investigating them or thinking about
them now and so there's no one
definitive answer of course that said I
think we do underestimate the sheer
numbers of countries and states that are
still quite familial in the early modern
European sense Saudi Arabia is a
dramatic example of course but there are
other countries and states that actually
have family provisions written into
their constitutions and of course some
even in Europe with some familial
components let's think of England for
example with under some situations of
course the current Queen of England
would actually have a pretty hefty
constitutional role so we can't consign
these forms of state and any easy way to
the past they are still with us today
not so much in contemporary America
mm-hmm but I was going to just ask you
about this country we don't really have
familial States Dewey families there's a
separation from government here at least
effort after
the early American history right that is
absolutely right we do grumble I know
about disproportionate power that some
families might have in parts of the
United States and that can certainly
still be true but these elite families
do not inherit state offices they do not
buy and sell them any longer they have
to get in them through democratic
procedures and in my opinion that's a
very good thing so in that sense we do
not however there are still aspects of
what we can think of as family
principles legitimating principles that
we still see intact in the united states
such as what well if you think for
example of September 11th and the
attendant national crisis an enormous
national crisis of course and one that
was highly mass mediated and therefore
present in just about every household in
the United States there was I think some
would argue and here I'm going a little
bit out on a limb but I'd I could get
your reaction to this a kind of longing
for a center central and reassuring
figure of power perhaps one that could
be simultaneously powerful and paternal
on the one hand but also comforting on
the other and if you recall on that day
in September 11th for quite some time
President Bush was not in evidence he
was not available to the media he was in
effect quote unquote for a short time
anyway missing in action there was a
kind of absent center in the American
state nation state and people felt it
deeply felt a sense of emergency
interestingly someone did step up to
fill that slot in just that fashion and
that was mayor Giuliani of New York
perhaps not a politician that we would
have expected to step up at that moment
certainly his finest hour I think both
the way in which he presented himself
and
way in which people responded to him
were in some sense familial dynamics but
these are things we see now in the
United States typically in moments of
emergency not everyday politics you
continue to be fascinated by the early
modern world but your more recent work
targets contemporary society and America
that's quite a leap how did you get here
from there well that's an excellent
question and I wonder whether I should
answer it honestly yeah or not well I
think I got there through true two
routes and one route really is a form of
happenstance that is for many years I've
been driving on American highways and
noticing 1 800 how am i driving stickers
on the back of trucks and I've been
interested and curious to see the
stickers and also to see the responses
that some truckers have written on this
on these stickers which I can't believe
mention on a family program like yours
then in recent years i noticed this kind
of addressed to a fictional I in the
workplace spreading to other places as
well the big box stores especially where
workers will wear a button or sometimes
even a uniform that says how am i
serving you so I became interested in
this fictive I how it operates whether
it actually does in train disciplinary
relationships how the workers feel about
it how it affects customers relations
and why it is spreading so rapidly
through many parts of the American
economy and polity now the name or one
name for this sort of phenomenon which
sounds a bit technical is agency
relations agency in both sense senses
that we use in everyday life both agency
in terms of how people act in terms of
themselves as an eye and also agents as
to whom we delegate think of for example
in real estate agents these are
contradictory senses of agency but
they're both present there in everyday
life why increasingly are those who are
to whom we are delegating certain tasks
and interacting with in that same way
called by the eye for example in
American life what's at stake here
what's the effect so I became interested
in this direction it also rose out of my
previous work in investigating early
modern European states I've always been
interested in these states and their
colonial offshoots the Dutch East and
West Indies companies and their French
and English and Iberian counterparts I
studied the impact of those companies in
Europe and on the colonies but i also
got interested in their organization in
their internal plumbing if you welder
her their agency relations what are the
relations of delegation between the
people in the bosses headquarters and
those on the ground and i found that
things were very messy indeed far
messier than i had ever thought yeah my
research let's talk about that a little
bit that sounds very interesting what
have you found and how did you actually
go about finding it out how did you do
your methodology or research for the
earlier work the earlier work I did sort
of extensive archival research in
multiple countries especially focusing
for that's part of the work on the East
Indies companies and when I began the
research I think I expected to find the
command structure to be much more
seamless than it was I expected orders
to be obeyed carried out and reported
back instead what I found was quite the
opposite so by the end of my research in
all these countries the puzzle rather
became how on earth to any of these
companies last for longer than a week
much less 200 years and how about today
did you find pretty much the same
situation more
so even more so as you might imagine now
in a period where the American
government consists of over 89,000
separate miniature sovereign units
certainly not related in any clear
hierarchical way now in a period where
we've moved from Hobbs's Leviathan to
google for government the relationship
between those who give orders or those
who ask for representation and those who
execute or represent is muddled and
becoming ever more so so that's what I'm
investigating okay so this is a new book
you're working on and it includes
empirical research on agency relations
in America so what are the big problems
you have identified and how are you
going to tackle them in your research
that's a very very good question and
since I'm at a very early stage of the
research I can answer it somewhat
speculative okay i can say that i'm
concentrating on several regions or
areas of American life one is work as I
mentioned with my example of the
trucker's and the clerks yes I am very
because I've seen those signs as well
and I often wonder do people even bother
to call in have you found that that is
the case people do call in and do they
say good things or predominantly bad
things excellent question they do and
they say both and with consequences for
the workers involved really yes so
they're actually it's comparable in some
ways to making a citizen's arrest so
there actually are consequences of these
call them disciplinary mechanisms okay
in the narrow sense of course for the
worker and those matter a lot but
they're also consequences for me and you
that is the consumer or those who
participate by calling in we might feel
empowered but we also might feel that we
are engaged in somewhat inauthentic
relations since what do you mean by and
often
well we're not engaging with the eye of
the worker we're being invited to
comment on that person's performance by
that person itself him or herself but
actually of course we are being invited
by the company right and our evaluations
are in turn being evaluated by a set of
companies to which that company
delegates its work call centers for
example across the united states in
India and elsewhere the pattern of both
discipline and accountability is ever
more diffuse and I'm sure that you at
least some time in your life have tried
calling the 1-800 number and the time
it's always quite the experience it's
always quite quickly not a good one and
typically not a good one so I actually
think that it matters that many people
like you and me are having not a good
experience and what kind of experience
is this is one thing I want to to
investigate so this is one area there
are more serious you could say our areas
of problems and agency relations and
delegations in America today for example
militarily increasingly vesting more and
more of our military force in security
companies abroad in Iraq and Afghanistan
and at home so it strikes me that to do
your current book you're going to have
to do a vast amount of research very
much unlike the written chronicles you
could access in your earlier book how
how are you going to do the research
that's a very good question Maryland
because this is a fundamentally
different kind of project it's one that
identifies different areas of
transformation of agency in action in
contemporary America almost in the forms
of symptoms of an underlying syndrome so
where am I going to diagnose those
symptoms and how I'm going to do how am
I going to do it well I'm going to focus
on
several areas where I am focusing on
several areas one is work as I mentioned
and let me say that this is already
itself quite extensive I'm in part
interested as well in the new forms of
American jobs that are arising at the
Nexus of these confusing and vexed
relations think for example of paste the
job of patient representative in the
hospital for whom does the patient
representative really work well it's not
as all at all clear they work for the
hospital for the family for the patient
sometimes for insurance companies
sometimes for doctors and sometimes for
themselves and that just scratches the
surface of the complexity so there are
jobs and employment relations like this
that are burgeoning at all sorts of
areas of the American workplace and I
would like to help people understand
those better as well so that work okay
but in order to get it at that would you
interview interview people would it be
like personal anecdotal kind of stories
that you would work or use or in
addition to something else yes there
there there a number of methods that you
can use and the methods will definitely
vary across show this text so they will
include interviews also ethnography /
participant observation also document
archival research and all of those I
have to mesh in one form or another and
the same is true also for the part of
the work that will focus on polity and
political representation and finally of
another part which i haven't mentioned
yet which I really have to introduce to
save the book and the project from being
impossibly depressing and dreary has to
do with those forms of Delhi
asian of the self and the I through
technics for example that are used more
for formation for foreplay okay so here
I'm thinking about things like online
collective video gaming for example or
even the way that you use your iPhone
okay which is a way of representing your
identity and in a sense sending it out
electronically across certain networks
to do all manner of things I would
imagine facebook would be huge Facebook
would be huge so I'm afraid I'm going to
actually have to get a facebook account
to which I'm not looking forward it's a
lot of fun you'll enjoy it okay that's
good to know okay so what do you hope
comes of your research what impacted you
hope it would have on the world well
that's a big question as well and one
that I think that all scholars should
always ask themselves in a way that
combines I think both humbleness and
hubris the humble in this part is that
one could probably only expect small
effects in the world on the world of
course but certainly you hope to clarify
certain things about people's lives that
others can learn from and build on and I
hope that for my own work of course
wonderful thanks so much for being here
with us today and sharing some of your
work for more information about
professor Adams and her work please
visit our website at yale edu backslash
macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you